I'm eight years old,
and it's my first day at the new school,
but I cannot express myself.
Actually, I don't understand
a single word of English.
My family just moved
from Korea to England.
My mom is raising my little sister and me,
and she's also finishing her degree.
She's nearly as lost as I am,
but with the little English she knows,
she speaks to my teachers
in broken English, every day,
about how she can help me at home.
Compared to many other parents
in the school who speak no English at all
or are even scared to ask the questions,
she's much better-off.
And for that, I'm much better-off.
Fast-forward three months.
Every time my mom picks me up,
a swarm of Korean parents
crowd around the car.
It causes a traffic jam,
like, every day. Seriously?
(Laughter)
All the other Korean parents
gather around the car,
asking my mom the same questions
that she asked my teachers.
"What is a parent-teacher
conference again?"
"My kid is behind. What can I do?"
I don't know how I'd have survived
that first year without my mom.
But I do know that my experience
is not that unique.
Every year, 50 million children
go through the US school system.
And out of that, 40 million,
that is, four out of five children,
come from underserved
or immigrant families.
We're talking about the vast majority
of the system here.
I realize that I'm one of the lucky ones,
because the law of averages will tell you
that these children
are likely to fall behind
by two whole school years.
This costs the US economy
almost one trillion dollars every year.
But it doesn't have to be that way.
In fact, research says
that for a student to do well,
a family's engagement is more important
than that family's wealth.
A parent is a child's first teacher,
and children spend 80 percent
of their waking hours
outside the classroom.
So no wonder families
are the game changer.
So here’s a trillion-dollar question:
How can we better tap
into the incredible potential of families
and their universal love
for their children?
This is why the organization I founded
helps teachers, families and schools
connect using something
that we all have:
a mobile phone.
Teachers write
the communication in English,
and parents receive it
in their own languages, and vice versa.
We break down the language barrier,
bridge cultural and knowledge differences
by explaining education concepts
and enable and prompt parents
and teachers to talk to each other.
We're playing the role that my mom played
for the school and my friends’ families:
the communicator,
the translator, the coach,
the explainer and the go-between.
And since my mom cannot be everywhere --
and, in fact, no parent can,
and that is not for the lack of trying --
we've stepped in and connected
four million families,
and students and educators
in 70,000 schools to date.
(Cheers and applause)
When families and schools
work together, everyone wins.
Students are supported,
families are empowered,
and teachers' jobs
just become that much easier.
The school environment and community
thrives with people from all backgrounds.
Even the system itself benefits.
Last year, the US spent
nearly 700 billion dollars
on school-aged education.
So imagine if you can increase
the return on that investment,
even just a little bit,
by connecting schools
to engage with all families.
And we should.
It's literally a no-brainer.
But actually, there's something
much bigger here
than student grades.
Education goes beyond economic growth,
and our goal goes beyond the classroom.
Schools are a funnel to the real world.
Public education makes citizens.
And in creating
the next generation of citizens,
we cannot be leaving behind
four out of five children
or their families.
If we continue to pick and choose
who the system engages with
generation after generation,
like we do now,
we will not be left
with a community, a civil society
or even a functioning democracy.
Our collective well-being
starts with inclusive schools
and helping every child
realize their endless potential.
So our hope is that one day,
all underserved and immigrant
children and their families
will feel that they belong
in the education system.
Our dream is that one day,
they'll feel included
in the very communities
that they're expected to build.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)